I had the pleasure to present to my  colleague our presidency priorities into  a coffin sector our work on the echo  Queen side will fall within three  overarching priorities of the finished  president's competitiveness climate and  security finally as usual in the July  ecofree meeting we adopt the country  specific recommendation today a coffin  discussed the own resources and  potential new sources of revenue for the  EU budget as you know the Commission has  proposed a basket of new own resources  linked to EU environmental and single  market policies national contribution  calculated on the amount of non recycled  plastic packaging waste in each member  state 20% of the revenues from the  emission trading system a share of a new  common console day to cooperate tax base  to facing once necessary legislation has  been adopted so we are looking forward  to work together with a Finnish  presidency and member states on this  farm